welcome to this video i'm playing z TFS
from Switzerland okay um so we get the
symmetrical gruene thought we should be
three that's not not very ambitious on
but possible can i play see 5 or is this
is this a better idea let's try this so
it's a bit bit ambitious but if he takes
energy form
it should be okay right I mean Bishop
see one this cannot be so great maybe if
maybe you just place h3 ok but let's let
me try to get this back age 39 f six
Bishop e3 this 94 Wow
okay he really wants to attack the d5
pawn badly hmm okay if I take it Bishop
takes e6 is pretty okay for me Queen
takes isn't this isn't this some
compensation at least yeah I can't
forget it for sure compensation e6 he
plays what before I guess I can well
let's just take a min Queen Queen takes
I mean Bishop takes e6 it's just just a
blunder and here I certainly have
compensation i'm not sure what exactly i
should play though queen bee six maybe
rope the eighth or queen takes just just
trading it all looks good really I'd
like to gain some more some more time on
the Queen
look the aid the next move
yeah close the door the washing machine
is problem in the background let's see
yeah it's definitely not easy to play
for wide at least this is my my
impression here I maybe just threatened
to take on v2 plus rope the aid okay so
let's just play this without wasting
much time we're now I can go to e5
gaining yet another temple not easy it
all looks looks pretty good young ok
going down and probably will put night
on d3m hmm
maybe
hmm I wanted to get to default actually
let's try that alrighty can play III
okay allows me to go that this is
probably good news c 2 and e 2 eggs
right I think you should have played III
or something like that or C 3 ok I can
take here I can take you to the Queen
here where's the Queen going actually
the ship f6e goes where to to where
I don't know where to before i take c 3
then
now can I definitely have a good
position but not sure if I played it
totally ride I can take take eat Ortiz
takes you one winning a piece okay this
is definitely okay check it's got 94 kb
should be seven okay if I was just
thinking I he was when the lucky escape
here in this position but I have two
should be seven okay maybe still has a
lucky escape Bishop g5 I can I can also
take this is not totally convincing take
a 92 I'm not sure that the night will be
able to escape this unbelievable that
this is still still a position for it ok
I can place you three at least c3 and my
night is no escape square what he came
yeah this is an additional problem time
warning 94a Bishop g4 f3 would be cute
made in one but you would probably not
overlook that it's not so easy to find a
good move against it down
ninety-two of the aid
I can play Bishop f3 now take stinks
yeah yeah come on let's do this for the
moment I'm a peaceable but both my
Knights look look weird
kingi 21 what is the idea I don't know
maybe here kimchi too okay theoretically
fatigue it cupcakes this also hangs well
I don't I don't know k check wow what a
position check now my nights are not
coordinated this is the problem maybe I
need to King somehow phone meeting
attack check
check
check
yes I don't see a med worth it yeah I
won't on time oh that's lucky I mean the
whole game was a total mess and probably
ever made somewhere yet I don't see it
though King g3 yeah okay I can just I
can just take this stuff I don't need to
meet him ja what this was a totally
wacky game around so I mean around here
I should just win I mean the problem was
I looked I saw this this win what I
thought I went a piece and this is not
the case I should have invested a couple
of more seconds like this this wins
Queen B 6 xiety to check here takes
takes takes takes something like this
yeah yeah witness a bit strong but I
will definitely win at least one pawn
and I have the bishop town they are
compass on minus one point seven yeah I
had this amazing that this is not
winning for black just just great and
then he was certainly winning I really
couldn't find a solution here the
Knights look totally trapped yeah I'm
not sure about that I thought c3
something like this would be good
compass on 0.1 and so like what do you
want nothing special okay and after this
it suddenly is ok for black minus 1 what
a weird game f4 and now look the aid is
the best
ok 193 yeah I went with his check and
simply I needed to play and this is so
crazy those nights are in white scam but
they are not coordinated this was played
d 8 now he played this strange move o
night ft 4 is good ok i am ok this is
this is indeed just winning up blocking
the default and now here d 5 and c5a
hanging ok yeah this is very this is
very convincing it also makes sure that
my Knights get out of the whole thing
and this is probably not as convincing
how black still should win according to
the comp this is the computer line and
this is just fantastic for those nights
but how is black going to win this the
compasses this is just nice it says I'm
winning but Jack but how how do i get to
untangle those pieces maybe h4 is the
big point I ok I but wait i have 3
pieces for the work right and it's so a
confusing I have three pieces young ok
this should really win and I mean now it
probably must take cannot allow h3 so
and if he takes then check yeah i get i
get my pieces coordinated yeah ok then i
probably will win i will win the the f
porn and the h1 I guess still some work
but crazy game ok well thanks for
watching